depuis des années notre monde vit en
paix mais des heures sombres ça lance je
le sens des forces obscures nous
menacent
trouver ses bêtes quelle qu'elle soit
notre monde se meurt
nous sommes condamnés à partir si notre
peuple veut survivre
devons nous établir ici
quoi qu'il advienne
quoi qu'il advienne nous devons nous
allier où notre monde est condamné
ce n'est pas une fatalité quelqu'un doit
pouvoir nous aider pour les orques les
vigies si la guerre
non avec l'aide des humains ça peut
changer cas venez vous faire sauver
notre peuple
on peut se fier à l'est
ce sont des bêtes
il faut les exterminer
en êtes-vous certain
nous protégerons le royaume vous et moi
tout à lyon subie contre les tiens
c'est du suicide nous n'avons pas le
choix nous devons attaquer en force
il faut se décider maintenant